I'm here in Newark on our criteria about
to get punished and these people are all
building and the things that I am going
to blend hello the ability buildings we
know I need someone a film farming first
we have
they are strawberry-flavored regular
probably mine is what flavor they are
hot dog
Karthik we're all rooting for a vegan
blender but it's not going to happen
this time
Soraka now spicy but you never have to
watch it cuz you're gonna want it to
have some heat before baby yeah I'll be
back you got a little bit uneven there
Oh
everyone stop being excited just now I
think I'm giving away the rest you're
sriracha it looks nice person in a
sailor hat peanut butter is happening
now I don't know how to get the peanut
butter around I got it
and our final item on the list
[Applause]
my third made it that's looking like
people who's never gonna be a better bed
breaker
all right oh oh come on get down there
oh oh it's worth every time okay
oh no yes there needs to be something at
it going to be almond milk because it's
all I have that's not that's not just be
clear they eat all of what is you think
that's not happening hopefully this will
work the distance all the locks are go
down in a blaze of glory I have five
deeply regretting some decisions I've
made in my past it looked like me
worried
it looks really really bad that's a
blender that I just heard yeah I wonder
now you just stay back there Miranda
you're stuck here you're like wait can I
smell it before you eat it
oh oh oh that was very bad I I wish
there was a way that we have
smell-o-vision here and we could just
pump the whole auditorium full of what I
just smelled you guys this is not in my
contract
can I get one more sniff before you take
a huge go I mean that is very very Bob
Josh
[Applause]
I have a little more left
when a vlog brother messes up my vlog
brother must be punished it's very quick
see it took a while without the hit the
peanut butter was masking it
[Applause]
Maureen is over good morning I put it
away
Rodney is taking taking it away except
for this cup part would you I'm not
going to be in funny legitimately queasy
so I guess this is connected Chuck do we
need to do it John I survived and it was
I think worth it I loved last weekend so
much thank you to everybody who came out
and thank you also to you John I'll see
you on Tuesday